so cave for chemists of course means
potassium the evil elements but it also
of course means Kelvin the absolute
temperature and because I'm interested
in how materials behave at different
temperatures I've been very familiar
with K in my doctoral work I did most of
my experiments at 20 K and so I've
always had a warm feeling from Kelvin
there are all sorts of funny stories
about him there's one story that he
asked a class of students what is
electricity and one student put up his
hand and when asked what is it he said
I'd forgotten and Kelvin said this is a
tragedy there are only two people who
know what electricity is one is God and
the other is mr. mckay who has forgotten
reason why we have this temperature
scale is because zero Kelvin Absolute
Zero is the coldest temperature which it
is theoretically possible to go to so it
is an absolute position of zero you
cannot actually ever get quite to zero
Kelvin but you can get within a
thousandth of a degree Kelvin or even
lower before that people chose zero for
their temperature scale by somewhere
that was fairly arbitrary well obviously
on the news they use Rho they used to
use the Fahrenheit temperature scale
which is quite arcane now or they can't
say that to an American and essentially
that's based on very human scales that's
based on a measurement of human body
temperature which is a slightly strange
thing to use as a unit in terms of
physics Fahrenheit thought he would make
zero the coldest temperature he could
get which was mixing snow and nitric
concentrated nitric acid so for him ice
melted at 32 and then he wanted to make
a hundred degrees the temperature of the
human body but unfortunately he got it
slightly wrong or perhaps he had a fever
that day so in fact the normal
temperature comes out at ninety eight
point four which is not
convenient but then water boils at 212
degrees Fahrenheit
so when Celsius came along we came up
with the centigrade scale which is
exactly what it says on the tin it's a
hundred steps and the steps are taken
from the freezing point of water to the
boiling point of water so we have a
hundred steps and a hundred being the
boiling point of water so the advantage
of the degrees Kelvin is that it there
is a theoretically justified reason why
you call zero zero nobody can get it
closer so you can never have a negative
temperature in degrees Kelvin so this is
the liquid fire for helium and the
temperature that we're talking about
here is one two degrees Kelvin and at
these temperatures superconductivity and
superfluidity come in right so the
reason that we have this here at the
University is because most of our
magnets that we use for things like
brain imaging and the various levitation
experiments that we like to do they all
use liquid helium to cool the magnets
down to superfluid temperatures as you
see it's a fairly big piece of
technology but what it all comes down to
is this you want to do this or what I do
this right here we've got here we've got
some liquid helium
what's your cooling down on the nozzle
here right it's slowly cooling there
quite rapidly cooling down and then very
quickly ready
wait for it
here it comes right and this is this
fabulous this is so cold you've got to
come and put your hand in it but it's
really great experience